this next story is going to sound
satirical but it's not I'm gonna play
audio and video for you of an elected
official a Republican state
representative who flipped out on a
Democrat because the Democrat touched
him on the arm because the Republican
isn't gay and doesn't want to be seen as
gay as a result of having been touched
on the forearm what yes
Darrell Metcalf is a Republican state
Rep in Pennsylvania he was this week
earlier this week in a house committee
meeting sitting next to Democratic state
Rep Matt Bradford Bradford was talking
and he briefly maybe it lasted a full
second maybe a fraction of a second
while addressing Metcalfe tapped him on
the arm Metcalfe interrupts and goes on
a homophobic diatribe that seems
indistinguishable from parody take a
listen to this there is a better way to
do this guys we don't have to proceed on
this one I hear ya I understand there's
some hard feelings with Penrith and
Bradford look I'm a heterosexual I have
a wife I love my wife I don't like men
as you might but don't stop touching me
keep your hands to yourself
like if you want to touch somebody you
have people on your side of the aisle
that might like it I don't okay chairman
chairman okay we're officially off the
rails it was a fraction of a second it
wasn't even a full second this Metcalfe
dude is a major known homophobe I've
been researching him and a few years ago
he used the legislative procedure to
prevent an openly gay state rep from
talking about the fact that the Supreme
Court had issued a gay marriage ruling
because it would have been quote an open
rebellion against Almighty God in God's
Word and I know that we often
exaggerated this entire if you're super
homophobic you're probably gay thing
it's not true right most homophobic
people aren't gay but yeah there are
dozens of notable exceptions that do fit
the bill but overall most homophobic
people are not gay people oh and if the
percentage is higher than the general
population though right maybe so maybe
maybe so but regardless you can't just
assume every homophobic person is gay
although there are dozens and dozens of
out spoke
homophobes who yes actually turned out
to be gay but broader numbers aside when
I see this kind of unnecessary and quite
frankly bizarre interruption of a state
rep just to assert heterosexuality for
me it raises major questions about
Metcalf security with his own sexuality
being touched on the arm by half for
half a second by another man raises no
questions about your sexual orientation
reacting this erratically actually does
right and I mean you know you have the
right not to be touched if you don't
want to but the proper way to go about
that is to pull the guy aside and
private well maybe not pullin I guess
you can't touch it yeah just to bring
him aside and say I don't like that
touch please don't do that again
you don't do it in public like that and
try to defend your heterosexuality very
bizarre and aside from the entire
homophobic a guy thing if Metcalf is so
emasculated by being touched on the
forearm for but for a fraction of a
second he should really be in therapy
plain and simple right and to quote a
recent hate reott mail this guy must be
a blast at parties right I can only
imagine what it's like to hang out with
this dude